[Music]
you absolutely look stunning
I love your hair you got the red hair
what are they doing here JIT you guys
call it in Europe you call it ginger
ginger yeah we just call us redheads or
the gifted ones kinetic notation but you
guys called gingers gingers yeah we're
kind of made fun of in the UK so it's
nice to come here when everyone's like
you really you don't find that you got
when I was a kid I got made fun of
oh really yeah yeah well for other
things too but but no it's a little more
accepted here but in it what you'd say
in Europe and you grew up in Scotland
yeah where everyone is ginger Oh
everyone's ginger yeah like Ireland
yeah well Ireland there's the dark
haired oh yeah we have some Irish and
then there's the kooky leprechaun I know
I'm serious I'm good I've been to
Ireland and they're these incredible
like handsome brooding Irish people and
I got to be one of the kooky ones but so
so everyone's redheaded where you come
from
yeah there's a lot of us okay yeah it's
interesting because you you're from what
part of Scotland you from I'm from
Inverness in the highlands next to Loch
Ness you're you near Loch Ness yeah you
go to Loch Ness a lot yeah all the time
really but you've never seen Nessie I
guess they call her no have you
oh you have yeah you've seen Nessie
really yeah just walking around going to
the pub you are so low key about Nessie
your accent is not that strong I
detected obviously but it's not that
thick impenetrable Scottish accent no
it's not like the pure beachy ones like
that yes yeah where do they come from
the Glasgow oh they're from Glasgow yeah
all right can you teach me any good
phrases Scottish phrases you guys have
such a great way with words anything
good I could learn okay here's one you
don't we discover what you know we've
gonna you're a wee schooner what does
that mean it means you're a little
nuisance
it's too late just go that's a good one
you're a wee scanner do we scanner don't
we sky that's pretty good I just made
noises - he what what I get another one
for me okay
goody keys a bag of chips pow what is
this goody keys ibaka chat spell go and
get us a bag of potato chips what's
power at the end or I'll hit you no it's
going to give us a bag of chips as in
not the crisps that you have here the
chips that we have oh and pal I just had
a small stroke but I'm gonna be fine
happy fine you know what I'm gonna tell
you a story and you've heard this a
million times but a couple of years ago
a friend of mine got married and he is
of Scottish descent and he asked all of
his friends the male friends to her kilt
and I did and he told me where to go to
get it and I bought the kilt and I
remember thinking I look good in this
thing cows are great I mean I was not
sure I thought oh no I look like I'm
wearing a dress again
police caught me but but I wore it not
it looked it looked good kilts you're
quite handsome when a man do you think
that's true yeah I think so
whoever I marry has to wear a kilt
really Yeah right all the time
no just at the wedding oh you know to be
a true Scotsman you you're not only to
wear anything underneath I've heard that
but that makes you laugh
well I can imagine why how are you
liking Los Angeles this is such a huge
change you're here now how is it for you
this is the antithesis of where I'm from
yes everyone works though all the time
there's sunshine all the time which I
can't really take and yeah everyone's
like really healthy and no everything's
fried yeah yeah you are the female me
work out at all and I also I love fried
foods and I cannot go in the Sun I'm
like one of the kids on Twilight I
cannot I cannot be anywhere near
sunlight oh I need a parasol I carry a
parasol
yeah and I'm beaten by everyone it's
tragic